I'm gonna do the AFC I got Chiefs over  Patriots I got Dolphins I like Bengals  over Titans again Bengals over the  Titans Joe Burr yeah I like bear and  then who oh yeah Bill's dolphins that  rematch oh man man I ain't even playing  but we're about to start we're about to  stop I could honestly Dolphins been AFC  champions this year  with their weapons they got and the  defense they got hold on I just went  through the NFC thing I went all the way  bro I told you I'm a realist bro I tell  you I can't make everybody happy you my  dog  but I looked at this Tyree and his  waddle match [ __ ] said the eagle I  know and I will understand  the truth  if it's not the Dolphins I like the  bills bro I told you a lot of bills I  love y'all too if it's not the Dolphins  I got the bills it's going to be the  winner between the bills and the  Dolphins and the AFC champion and that's  going to be the champion